[موسيقى]
الجونة هي واحدة من الوجهات الأكثر شهرة في
جميع أنحاء العالم التي تدعو إلى
[موسيقى] ،
والرياح المشمسة المستمرة ،
والمياه الضحلة حولت الجونة إلى
وجهة عالمية لراكبي الأمواج بالطائرة الورقية ، وقد
استضفنا العديد من
المسابقات
الدولية لمومو أفضل شغف بهذه الرياضة
بدأت في سن مبكرة في المرة الأولى التي رأيتها
فيها ، كان عمري 14 عامًا في منزلي ، لقد
رأيت للتو رجلًا يقطع ، ثم
كنت أشاهده وكأنني معجب
تمامًا كما لو أنني سأفعل ذلك منذ
هذا اليوم مثلي  وقع في
حب الرياضة ، مومو هو واحد من عدة
مدربين يعملون في مدرسة ركوب الأمواج بالطائرة الورقية
في الجونة ، وهو منتجع تم بناؤه خصيصًا
على طول الساحل الغربي للبحر الأحمر ،
وهو اليوم يصطحب مجموعة من راكبي رياضة ركوب الأمواج بالطائرة الورقية
إلى واحدة من أفضل الطائرات الورقية في العالم.
في حين أن عمر مودريتش البالغ من العمر 16 عامًا تعد جزيرة النقرة
واحدة من أشهر الوجهات
لركوب الأمواج في جميع المستويات بين
طلابه ، فأنت
بالتأكيد تحصل على اندفاع الأدرينالين كلما هبطت.
عندما تتعلم خدعة جديدة ، فإن
الشعور هو أنك لا تستطيع وصفها حقًا
على الرغم من أن أوما لم يمارس رياضة ركوب الأمواج بالطائرة الورقية إلا
منذ خمس سنوات ، فهو بالفعل بطل حاصل
في مصر ، حلمي هو أن أصبح
بطل العالم لأنه سيأتي
إليك يومًا ما
[موسيقى]
مع سرعة رياح تصل إلى 50 كم / ساعة
في موسم الذروة ، هناك فرصة
كبيرة لمومو لاختبار مهاراته مما
يعني أنه لا يزال هناك الكثير
لنتعلمه بالتأكيد سأستمر في تعلم كل يوم
مسارات جديدة تشعر بها عندما
أنت هناك مع طائرة ورقية والرياح
ليس لديك محرك ليس لديك زيت
ليس لديك غاز أو أي شيء يشبه
نوعًا من الحرية أشعر
أنني لن أتوقف حتى آخر يوم
لي كما سأستمر
لبقية حياتي
[موسيقى]